[Music]
this is gonna feel good
welcome to the pilot of my new weekly
YouTube show not normal
[Music]
[Music]
six months ago in Dublin Island if you
take the clock even further back to
around a year and a half ago I was in
Mumbai
directing a TV commercial for the Indian
premiere what was on the super big set
with hundreds of people everywhere I've
become everything
I couldn't stand an egocentric TV
commercial very active fueled by
creating Brad narratives for major
companies with no real value to the
people that watched them other than to
sell them something after I called rap I
flew back home to South Africa and
decided to start right from the
beginning again to figure out my [ __ ]
purpose in the world of film and media
my friend Casey then offered to teach me
the ropes of running a successful
YouTube channel by taking me along on
the ride with him or hating his new
daily show so flew to New York and
decided to give being a youtuber ago I
began to find meaning within filmmaking
again which is super strange perception
shift from someone who used to pride
themselves on aesthetic work that took
months to create not these daily YouTube
videos but the constant creative
stimulation and pressure of having to
click the upload button hope to be
almost instantly we went on to create
something new every day for 100 days I
went from being a taste dummy for pizza
delivery drone to CP on the floor in
London but not once was I concerned if I
made the right move by leaving
traditional TV commercial globe there
anything behind as soon as I decided I
wanted to do this for good I applied for
what you call an o1 visa I'm just gonna
pause there for a second basically the
way that it works even though South
Africa is no longer considered a third
world nation it's still treated as such
when it comes to border control and then
when it comes to acquiring a working
permit that's in a whole nother league
of its own the working visa that I
applied for is known as the Oh 1 visa
which is arguably the most complicated
permit to acquire and basically need to
be at the top of your game in the
sciences arts or sports reading this
description gives me complete anxiety I
hate how this works but I guess it has
to be done I was super fortunate to win
a few young directors Awards I can and I
just really hope to push the visa
process forwards I just want to say that
I'm super grateful for all those
opportunities and for everybody that's
helped me along the way but before it
could get signed off I had to fly to
Belfast and Ireland to say a speech
ironically about my next moves when I
would get back to New York and how I was
gonna start a new season on my channel
but when going through immigration at
the airport on my way back the officers
wouldn't let me back in the country on
suspicion of being paid to whoa an
important note everything I did was
aboveboard
I was aware that I would have to find my
way through those six months so I
planned accordingly but in their eyes
who would make films for free
I would I was made to return home in
South Africa I contacted the lawyer they
said it could take any time from a week
or a year but I just couldn't base my
future on a timeline like that so I
shifted around six months of my career
and began my previous ascent for this
time from a completely different side of
the mountain all because I couldn't flop
my idea of creating a purple community
of brew so I began to transform this
garage into a collaborative working
space called the brew headquarters to
keep the flag flying high from the
southernmost tip of Africa I hired Jonah
and Luke to help me put together the
next meteoric stay not normal I did a
ton of brand deals for the first time
this year and even though I tried my
best my channel took a bit of a knock
but it's all part of the banana see
cause he was I was able to save a lot of
cash
my new
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] so Dan what do you been up to
I'm back in New York yeah I know I mean
ah thank you
obviously we're in my office tell me
something like don't know but then what
else are you okay I'm starting a new
YouTube show okay which is called not
normal
I built this map where you can come on
as the viewer and plant your seed which
is an idea and I will fly to you to
complete that any idea that pops into
your head that fills you with joy
curiosity or some sort of firing desire
I will come and help you finish your
thoughts
what if somebody is in like Thailand
I'll fly the Papa New Guinea New Zealand
I'll go back there when are you starting
this it starts today when are you gonna
leave New York in three weeks just out
here dad I know but then I'm coming back
okay I have to do this this is that's
essentially what I want to do and
utilize YouTube for now and that sounds
awesome make sure you go to Dan's web
site and plant your seed inside one
righteous seed on the side not in the
Sun not in that sounds awesome Dan make
sure you go to Dan's web site and plant
your seed today
Zek it sounds good 50 bucks okay
welcome to the not normal map where the
show really starts with you start by
entering one your city and to your seed
my team then selects the most compelling
seeds each week to become a
collaborative video between you and I
around the globe wherever you are this
is not normal it dedicated outlook on
following through on more of your
thoughts well just before we end this I
just want to say thank you to bnh for
sponsoring all the gear for season two I
was able to go to their headquarters and
choose all the gear that we would need
to make this possible so thank you being
H it's really incredible to be able to
say that we've developed a relationship
and another major sponsor of season 2 is
epidemic sound they made the archer
track it's dope I'm gonna play it now
don't forget your awesome brew and I'll
see you when season two starts in three
weeks time